hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 48 er stellt die blumen auf den
tisch
er stellt die blumen auf den tisch
die blumen stehen auf dem tisch die
blumen stehen auf dem tisch
er stellt die schuhe vor die tür
die schuhe stehen vor der tür
er legt den teppich auf den boden
der teppich liegt auf dem boden der
teppich liegt auf dem boden
sie legt das kissen auf das sofa sie
legt das kissen auf das sofa
das kissen liegt auf dem sofa das kissen
liegt auf dem sofa
er hängt das bild an die wand
das bild hängt an der wand
er setzt sich auf den stuhl
er sitzt auf dem stuhl
der schreibtisch steht vor dem fenster
der schrei
steht vor dem fenster
das regal steht neben dem fenster
die lampe steht in der ecke
die lampe
in der ecke
die bücher liegen auf dem tisch die
bücher liegen auf dem tisch
die pflanz
steht hinter dem sofa
hinter dem sofa
die
hängt über dem bett
über dem bett
die personen sitzen am an dem esstisch
dpa
sitzen am an dem esstisch
die karte
läuft unter dem tisch
die katze
oft unter dem tisch
das lava
wo steht zwischen der dusche und der
toilette
das lama
steht zwischen der dusche und der
toilette
meine wohnung hat vier zimmer meine
wohnung hat vier zimmer
meine wohnung ist im dritten stock
meine
nun ist im dritten stock
es gibt einen
cohen
es gibt einen balkon im wohnzimmer steht
ein esstisch im wohnzimmer steht ein
esstisch in der küche gibt es einen
kühlschrank in der küche gibt es einen
kühlschrank
das bett steht im schlafzimmer das bett
steht im schlafzimmer meine wohnung ist
im erdgeschoss
meine
nun ist im erdgeschoss es gibt einen
garten es gibt einen kleinen garten plus
wechsel präposition gibt dativ plus
wechsel präposition gibt da tief
wohin plus wechsel präposition gibt
akkusativ wohin plus wechsel präposition
gibt akkusativ
[Musik]
nein